this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
[Laughter]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
we're here with our returning champion
rob bell is in the studio
this is his victory lap
you know uh there were earlier laps
you were our first ever guest on on the
minimalist before then i think we did
like 100 episodes alone
and then we did a a um live event with
you in los angeles
and we put that up and you were that was
the first guest on on the minimalist
seriously yeah and now you're the last
guy i was just gonna make that joke
anyway we're here on the occasion of
rob's new book everything
is spiritual rob let me just say this
this
is the book i was hoping you would write
oh wow i just gotta take that in for a
minute that's good
you know it's uh i mean i've read
past books really really enjoy you know
uh how to be here
velvet elvis loved ones etc but but this
book in particular
it feels in many ways like
well it couldn't have happened until now
yeah
and well it's a history it's also
looking forward
at the same time yeah
well done there yeah that's all baked
into it
let's talk a bit about this book why now
you have to own every square inch of
your story
otherwise you have all these like bits
and pieces
you don't know what to do with the
embarrassing stuff the awkward stuff
the heartbreaking stuff the stuff that's
like locked in a black box
at the bottom of the ocean um but
everything is spiritual like
spirit is in all of it and when you look
back on your life
the awkward embarrassing heartbreaking
tragic stuff
is often where the new life came yeah
like you crashed you hit the wall you
ended up face down you know what i mean
yeah and then you look back and you're
like
oh wait in that grief and pain were all
these seeds of imagination of a new
life yeah so there are all these
categories that most
people live enslaved to good bad
right wrong winning losing success
failure of these
binaries these dualities
and yet there's something lurking in all
of it
there's something under it through it
there's like a like an electricity like
a
charge like i mean in the ancient
tradition spirit
and that's where the new creation comes
you don't avoid you don't try to get rid
of your anxiety you listen to it because
it's
telling you something about who you are
and what's off
uh it's a restlessness that there could
be more yeah
so in some senses that's why now as you
get to a point where you realize
it was all okay and it wasn't just okay
it's like a
to be here is like a wondrous
glorious experience yeah and senate we
tried cynicism
you know what i mean a bunch of people
moved to brooklyn you know what i mean
rolled their eyes
we tried all that you know what i'm
saying we tried cynicism yeah yeah
didn't work yeah standing at a distance
pointing out everything's wrong with
everything
some people still need to like try that
out for themselves we gave that a good
shot but innocence
wonder aw the sense that you're
wide-eyed and you're here
we're doing this that's where it's at
so yeah that's why now there's a line in
the book that stood out to me there's
quite a few that i have underlined but
this one i wrote down my understanding
of god was suddenly shifting
something less out there and more right
here right now
um how has your your faith evolved
a lot of people will know your backstory
some people won't we could cover it
briefly but
um how has your your faith evolved
because
ryan and i have two different belief
systems i think we have the same
values but but we we believe something
different but i think those beliefs
are are ever evolving as as we learn as
we go through some of those crashes
as well how do you feel like uh you've
evolved since say
98 or 2011 in what ways
well is the book 300 pages so there's a
start to the answer
yeah um from from when i was a kid
i remember having the sense that there's
more going on here
this thing the universe is not a cold
dead place
it was even the earth i tell these
stories about soil and water and trees
and rocks like
some sense that this thing is alive or
it's humming or something
that's really important because for so
many people their
intuitive understanding
of the nature of this thing um
they were right on like how many people
for how many people religion
actually jacked up their understanding
it gave them a bunch of
things that weren't helpful but they
intuitively the whole time had a sense
like
we're all connected this thing does
matter
you know what i mean i'm here for some
reason if that's even the word you'd use
for it
so uh i had that sense
at a young age and sort of followed it
and in the world i came from well
that's religion and then i was like i
love talk i want to help people like
with these mysteries
so that became like go be a pastor study
i got a master's degree in divinity a
master's in divinity let's pause for the
absurdity of that
a master of
deep mysteries you see what i'm saying
all right you are like if you don't see
the
absurdity baked into that
minimalism so it's like i followed those
i i
because our tribes like give us like a
path like this is how you do
it and every group tribe family system
has like its ladder
climb this way but uh
it was always like that wasn't it was
always the thing in here
that was like it's good it's good to be
here keep going keep following it
yeah so sort of just keep following it
everything is spiritual i mean the
the title comes from a talk you gave a
few years ago right
and um um when someone sees that title
they're going to start getting all kinds
of
conceptions in their mind right
um what why choose this title because
there are other titles you could have
used to describe the same exact book
yeah
yeah the first everything is spiritual
tour was in 2006 it was about quantum
physics
and mysticism and dimensional theory
all the sort of what like what we know
from science about the world is
what is we're not a ball
a rock hurtling through space at 67 000
miles an hour
um and then the second tour was in 2015
which expanded on this and talked about
it
this evolving universe that never stops
expanding it's omnicentric every
place in the universe is actually the
center of the universe because it never
stops expanding so i was
i had some ideas about the third one
which would be just more like
mind-blowing ideas about
science and spirit and what's happening
here and what this
what we know about this experience we're
having but
i kept coming back to their just ideas
where did how did i come to these ideas
you know what i mean because it's easy
to be stuck in your head and and just
minds talking to minds you have
information you ever be
i say this you say this we just trade
but there's like
what shaped our souls um what were those
experiences and i found myself
like wait how did i come to see the
world the way that i do
um what what shaped me
and it was the strangest thing because
suddenly i was like oh
my grandma used to keep cash in her bra
which is the first line of the book yeah
and i'm suddenly i'm back on the porch
with my grandma
because we would sit out on her farm on
the porch and the wind would blow across
the tops of the feet
across the corn in the fields and
sometimes we would just sit for a while
in silence and i realized that was my
first experience of the
wordlessness of grace when the presence
of another person communicates to you
that everything's fine
even if it isn't i remember just i burst
out like in tears
like oh sitting on the porch with my
grandma like that
did something to me and then suddenly
that became
what was interesting so i just followed
it into my
the generations before me um
yeah so then it became oh that's the new
because those tours had giant
whiteboards that i would fill in right
oh we're the white board like you
josh are you ryan like that's the
greatest mystery that's as mysterious
your interiors are as fascinating as the
exteriors of the solar system you know
what i mean yeah so it became
could i write a book that captured what
it's been like to be me in such a way
that it was holding a mirror
up to you and what it's like to be you
because the universal is found in the
particulars so you go far enough into
the aches and pains and details of your
life
that's how we all will find ourselves
yes that's what happened yeah it was
unbelievable to write it
you know the first time i met you i
remember telling you how
you helped me hold place for god
essentially
and i was so on the fence of like having
you even talk about in your book with
the woman and her husband who committed
suicide
that god yeah having that death of the
god that you believed in some gods die
yeah and that happened to me and i had
no idea where to go
and um you really helped me hold space
for at least possibilities but
i bring that up because you did a
masterful job of doing this with
spirituality
it's like uh i'll use the word energy
sometimes all the energy in the room
or like the energy of a city and every
time i say it i cringe a little bit yeah
because i'm like you have a woo reflex
yeah exactly there's a little
reflex and i'm like i don't know another
word for it but i'm just feeling
something right now
but it's r and it's real it is real and
i think now
i can look at it as a spirituality in a
way that energy absolutely yeah and this
is the great quandary of the modern
world
is as soon as you had the birth of
scientific
materialism which is we can measure this
world we can go in a lab and study it
which was incredibly important because
we have microphones and airports and
hospitals and like the modern world was
built on this rigorous
rationality but the underside of that
was it tended to value things that could
be empirically measured things you can
access with your five senses things you
can hold in your hand
and so realities of life that can't be
accessed in those ways
inevitably diminished soul spirit
even this phrase people use like woo-woo
like i don't know
um it's yeah but for thousands of years
that's just as real so something can
have form like this cup
um but something can have zero physical
form and be just as real
an idea love
hope so in some senses we're like
children of a system that's so heavily
prized
one dimension of the human experience
the exterior objective
and that you can like win that game now
in the modern world
and know next to nothing about interior
subjective what's it like to be ryan
aches desires yeah so spirituality has
always been the naming of that
because it's just as real and you can
see people
rediscovering this because you have to
essentially
the rediscovering thing is fascinating
because i as soon as i read this there
were all kinds of people i thought
were the appropriate audience for this
but i found them like all over the place
like it wasn't
a particular demographic right it was
like
oh i know this guy or gal who
has there's always this pendulum that
swings right it's like
and you talk about this a little bit in
the book where where you go from you
know
uber religious to uber atheist
or you know hedonistic to to ascetic
right and and it leaves very room very
little room for the
giant spectrum in between these two
poles but to me
this book is like it's the room in
between
which is where all the interesting stuff
is yeah like the
people will tell you a story like and
then i like
was was talking to them and i mean we
found all this common ground and i mean
i'm a whatever and they're from whatever
and then they refer like
they're shocked because they walked into
the situation with these labels
about their this and this person's this
but then i mean we found out we have all
this stuff in common it's like
yeah so how about next time just start
there
yeah we're humans we do have some
questions about labels we got some other
questions and this is an audience driven
show so i should probably dive into some
of these questions here
we've got one from kat in savannah
georgia i was just wondering
if you guys tend to use the law of
attraction
to help manifest minimalism
and or any sort of success or whatever
it is that you want in your life
and how that has been for you rob when i
hear kat's question why do i
i tense up when i hear two things i hear
law of attraction and all of a sudden
i and it's my own uh negative response
it's the woo-woo radar it's the woo-woo
there's something there but then also
the word manifest like it's another woo
alarm bell for you for whatever reason
it
is it's nails on a chalkboard for me and
it shouldn't be and i should be more
open-minded to things like this
um because when i hear it i almost don't
even know what it means
notice is that a question
[Laughter]
was there a question at the end of that
sentence
yeah what uh why do i have this allergy
there we go
allergic to woo-wooiness uh my guess is
you
have a instinctual reflex
against something that seems to
take this vast mysterious
extraordinarily generative universe and
boil it down to
one law it actually feels to you
too minimalism too simplistic
so the impulse in the question is
wonderful how you think about things
profoundly shapes what they even are so
that's why her
her question is so powerful is she has
come into a way of understanding
the power of how you choose to name the
experience because that shapes what the
experience even
is so an example would be
uh recently i was talking to this guy
who said
to me and he was he was lovely he was
talking about his own life and he now
has a daughter and he's married and he's
exploring how he's going to live he's
young um
businessman and he said you know every
generation
wants to one-up the generation before it
hmm
i was like okay first off totally
understand the impulse
but let me say that word back to you and
tell me how your body hears that word
one up he's like oh
tense it's like yeah one up is what he
said
uh competition i said fall that
competition meaning what he's like oh
win or lose oh and then you evaluate
yourself whether you want or lose so
that phrase sounds wonderful each
generation wants to one-up the one
before it but what it actually
the experience of it is a tense
experience of scarcity
so there's all of these energies hidden
in a statement like that that can just
fly right under the radar like oh yeah
every generation
um so the the power of thinking about
how you think about the world
is it alerts you to all the ways that
you're actually framing your experience
in ways that aren't going to take you
anywhere you want to go
yeah the the language is so powerful you
can improve upon that you can even use
the word improve upon you could say
each generation wants to improve upon
the previous and all of a sudden you've
give more there you go hand less to
unlearn yeah yeah wonderful impulses
so underneath the question let's go back
to why you threw up in your mouth
at the question the truth is
there are these extraordinarily subtle
shifts in how we view everything so one
example was
you can view life through a lens of
scarcity and lack
or you can view life through a lens of
abundance
and generativity generosity and these
are
they exist almost so deep in the self
that you can't even see them
you know i mean they're so close in here
but they're actually what you look
through the gift of something like
law of attraction it simply alerts
people to if i am
operating from a place of scarcity and
lack then i'm going to see everything is
competition the goodness that comes to
others will always be a threat to me
which leads to jealousy and envy
and it ultimately shrinks heart and soul
if i see the earth and this world
believing in is abundant and can provide
for all
and i'm going to be fine that's going to
profoundly
shape things how's that yeah
look at you he's twitching less
well i do think about the language with
with my daughter in particular so
uh our our the way we end every episode
is love people use things because the
opposite never works
and and the problem is we often say we
love
something like i love ryan but oh man i
love these chairs
right and same word for chairs and ryan
right and we have a language problem
really right and
every new chairs can be that awesome and
ella always argues with me she's like
but i
love my robe and i'm like and it made me
realize like oh
like this is what children do is they
love things and they get confused with
you know the things that they love and
and it's misplaced priorities and all
these other things it's because they're
children they don't have a fully
developed prefrontal cortex and and
but we as adults don't we do the same
thing
i still say i love this chair and i i
get attached to to
these things i give meaning to things
that don't deserve that meaning right
well it's interesting because you know
if i say i love you
versus i love that chair it's too
completely different
emotions right and and it's interesting
how i mean this goes back to the
language thing if you're looking at just
the language the law of attraction
sounds really silly but like when i
think of the law of attraction
it's it's very emotional for me like
it's not like
oh if i think i'm gonna make a million
dollars it's gonna drop on my lap it's
more like
uh what would i do with that why do i
want a million dollars what am i gonna
do with that oh what i really wanna do
is
i want to be financially free i want to
be able to give to others
so then i start to focus on that which
leads to actions to do that
which really even in the movie what is
it called the secret
the law of attraction movie i mean every
single one of those people who they
interviewed
there was so much action that went
behind their law of attraction
but that like i feel that though when i
see hear the law of attraction it's like
i feel the action that comes along with
it
so yeah i uh yeah you and i kind of
disagree on that the love thing
um i agree with you and i try to use it
that way that we talk about
um but if someone says it like i don't
let it interrupt
their moment that they're experiencing
you know i don't know
yeah yeah cut ella some slack man
cat i'm gonna send you a copy of
everything is spiritual uh rob bell's
new book it just came out today by the
way if
you're listening to this the day that
this episode came out we have another
question from luis in sao paulo brazil
how do you guys relate to religion to
the lifestyle of minimalism
well rob when ryan and i talk about
minimalism we're talking about
minimalism as a lifestyle in particular
i mean
there are other forms of minimalism
obviously when i talk about
donald judd or brad easton ellis and
laurie moore
um when we talk about minimalism as a
lifestyle it's you know living
a meaningful life with less trying to
figure out the things that truly add
value to our life getting rid of that
which is superfluous
to make room for that which is important
and so
how do you how do you relate that to
religion or spirituality
well historically if you think about the
word religion
in the middle is this l-i-g it comes
from the latin
the latin is this word root is this lig
is this word lagare which means to bind
or
connect so so that's where ligament
comes from because it binds these two
things together so
if you think about the etymology like
the structure of the word religion
religion is what holds you together
so that that's its intent otherwise
life pulls you in a hundred different
directions you like disintegrate so
religion was always
what are the practices or rituals what
are the things you do
that hold you together
so what you all have been doing with
this message of minimalism
is very religious at its core you're
inviting people to be held together by
something other than
unthinking uncritical consumerism just
the accumulation
there's more to life than the
accumulation of dead objects
um so when people talk about religion is
a bad thing but then they say but my
friend they do that religiously
yeah they do that on a regular basis
because it helps give coherence
and holds them together now the problem
in modern culture for many people is
religion did the opposite it actually
split things apart
it created tribes not community yeah
yeah yeah
so it like collapsed in on itself for
many people that was their experience
which is fine but it doesn't mean that
we won't just find other things to be
religious about
so the person's like i walk my dog every
morning i take a jog training for yeah
of course you do
yeah i have a meal with my kid every day
yeah of course you do there are these
things that you do that
hold you together they bind you bind you
to a sense of larger
purpose meaning divinity um
binds you to other people yeah yeah so
what you all do is actually very
religious wow
you didn't see that coming no you made
me you made me feel good about it
well because you know what's interesting
is like when we first started this
people were like what are you doing
starting a cult
and i was like no not a cult because
because cult leads itself you know
because once a cult gets big enough it
becomes religion
but uh but you know i actually really
like what we do
because there's no dogmatics to it in
religion and the sense that you talked
about i
can actually own that and be like yeah i
i totally
there there is a religious thing going
on as far as
looking at something greater than what's
in front of us
absolutely this is and it wasn't just
well you think about it in terms of
religion for many people was a head game
what do you believe
like you said no dog what do you believe
how is your
mental furniture arranged that became
but historically religion was always a
path
like how do you live yeah like it was
economic it was political
it was a way of ordering your life and
ordering the world like in the bible
over and over again the bible is about
how does the world get ordered
um if there's a widening gap between
rich and poor
that's destructive for everybody if you
don't live with the earth
in the earth in a sustainable way
everything falls
apart so the question is how does the
world get ordered and in some senses
what you've done is create a space
that raises questions for people about
how do you order your world
because there are ways of ordering the
world that just lead
to despair and a sense of empty what is
going on here and there are ways
that lead you to community and love and
connection and all that
you guys are way more religious than you
realize that
is a great tagline minimalism the
philosophy on how to order your world
i was thinking you're gonna say
minimalism we are way more religious
i think that's that's number two this is
from uh
the criticism section on the minimalist
wikipedia page
um so a few things in here about
religion according to the dallas morning
news more than a few have ascribed
religious underpinnings to the
minimalist work
but milburn insists the minimalists are
not a faith-based business
and we don't believe in the law of
attraction here's one that rob will
appreciate
in an article titled your minimalist
lifestyle is quasi-religious
anti-poor [ __ ] vice magazine
condemned the minimalists as
quote glowing examples of as asceticism
as solution
ascribing deeply religious motives to
their movement because
they are quote a pair of white dudes who
travel the world to proclaim the joys of
simplicity
and just happen to be close friends with
evangelical legend
rob bell just so evan
yeah this is this is what is where is
this coming no this is an article that
was written about us
uh the article goes on to claim yeah
blah blah blah anyway um
i guess what rob is saying is yeah we
the vice is right
yeah damn we didn't even know it they
knew it before we knew it
pretty much pretty much every wisdom
tradition
had in it some space
for uh
i was gonna say that's not the right
word for
living i would call it closer to the
earth
you generally find these polarities of
feasting and fasting
sometimes what is needed is a
celebration of the abundance of life
a big table with lots of food and
everybody comes to it
yeah sometimes sometimes you need to
feast
yeah but other times fasting which would
be simply
going without is how you realign
how you awaken um and so you can see
anytime somebody parks themselves at one
of those two
you've missed that sometimes it's time
for feasting
and sometimes it's time for fasting
so so the aesthetic the one who
withdraws
or the one who intentionally goes with
less or without
that's always been one of the ways that
people
found their soul lived with integrity
realigned re-centered experienced
rebirth
so it's funny when the aesthetic is
spoken about of
derisively because that's like a
thousand-year-old human pattern of one
of the ways that people have helped
check themselves and realign themselves
you know what i mean yeah it's just
fascinating to see it seen as like
sort of trivial or something when yeah
the witness
of like the cloud of witnesses across
history has been yeah sometimes you need
to
go live in a cave for a bit sometimes
you need to give away your stuff that's
that's all part of the thing i think any
new idea
or i mean minimalism isn't a new idea
but maybe
an an old idea for a new any old idea
that appears unfamiliar
yeah what's interesting it gets
criticized so the the problem now that
we have you know especially around 2008
we had
this whole collapse is we we realized
for the first time like
massive amounts of debt we spend 1.2
trillion dollars a year on non-essential
goods
uh in the united states alone and and so
you look at something like that and you
realize like
oh we're wasting our money which we have
to work a lot of time
to get to buy things we don't want or
need we're going into debt
we have this huge problem with over
indulgent
over consumption and i think around the
crash
it was a reset it was a crash for people
to realize like oh
maybe the way that we're living is is
wrong some people made some changes
around the time
ryan and i um we we stumbled across this
whole minimalism thing
but then over the last decade i think we
faced a new problem
with social media and and 24-hour news
cycles
every minute of every day now we're
facing this
over we're overly distracted as well so
not only are we over over
consuming stuff but we're over consuming
discrete inputs and you know we're we're
being bombarded with hundreds of
thousands of discrete inputs every
single day
and what we're saying is you don't have
to be an ascetic and go live
in a cave but maybe you can look at what
what their recipe is
and tweeze out a few ingredients and see
what's appropriate for your own life
yeah yeah maybe like one day a week you
don't check your email
and for many people that creates a low
grade panic but 20 years ago you didn't
have emails so a thing that you didn't
have like think about that feeling when
you misplaced your phone
and just what that sends
like neurochemically through your body
the agitation
level of a thing that you didn't use to
know existed
yeah like a tiny little machine you
carry in your pocket you now if you
misplace it
my whole life is on that phone yeah you
start going through the things so this
is brand new immediately
this is brand new humans haven't ever
had this
sort of experience that we're having
with these machines
makes me think about how you brand new
you talk about the molecules being
brand new and the atoms being brand new
at a certain point and uh
yeah where is technology going to take
us it's like we're in it right now we're
in the brand new right now
yes yes and we're just now learning like
you think about
how the algorithms and social media are
bent towards the outrageous
yeah so this person comments hey i
really enjoyed that
the algorithm is like whatever this
person's like you suck
heat center throbbing heat center you
know what i mean and then this person
piles on
i mean the machines are literally tilted
towards the outrageous
i mean if you if you understood that
you could become president
[Laughter]
wait a minute that the machines are bent
in a particular direction so
every person who's like how did 2016
happen
much better question how
aware are you of your role in that
because every time you click something
outrageous
yeah you are reaffirming that the
algorithms are bent in the proper
direction
and that's the the biggest problem with
with the advertising model i i
appreciate that you don't do
advertisements in your podcast and um
there are a few other people out there
who don't and
and the reason we don't is when we want
people to support us for the right
reasons you know thank thank you to our
patreon supporters who who support us
and keep us in this podcast space but
what
what i've realized with the advertising
model is it's
only about aggregating eyeballs because
the more eyeballs that are on
your newspaper or tv show or whatever it
is
the more they can charge for advertising
and so they no longer need to add value
to an audience they simply need to
aggregate or herd an audience to
their platform and in doing so they make
more revenue well how do you do that
you you amp up the the outrage and then
of course as you say
we are complicit in in the clicking and
the viewing
and then not turning it off yeah so
yeah going back to spirituality
spirituality is a heightened awareness
of what these forms that we have created
are doing to us because spirit animates
forms
so we are surrounded by these forms and
these new forms are shaping us
so you can see people waking up to wait
these machines and the algorithms
are actually doing things to us and we
have tremendous power to shape them
to resist to form neural pathways
there's always an empowerment of they're
doing this to us but
they don't have to yeah we can set it
down we can not click
all that it's interesting it
makes me think like i look at uh
like my dad right now who's like very
devout jehovah's witness
it's the it's evil in the world it's
this evil you know it's satan and his
demons and they're affecting the world
and i have that also that world died for
me too
and the way i look at it now is a
perfect example is social media we look
at it and we say oh man look at all the
evil look at what satan's doing with
the technology and all this influence
but it's
us who is doing it as my dad
switches to fox news and then he goes to
their website
and then he looks at all the bad going
on he is becoming part of it
and it's interesting because the way i
look at evil now is
like i can take responsibility for my
own evil yeah instead of
making it a spiritual thing and saying
oh there's an entity that's making me do
this it's like i can look at it like
that's actually coming from here
right you don't need to project your
shadow onto some external
character right you could just own your
part in it and take responsibility and
grow up absolutely and then when lots of
people do that things change
yeah ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it is time for our lightning
round where we answer
questions well from your from your text
messages you can text your questions and
comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those
texts go to both of our phones because
we're a little bit crazy
um and we do respond to some people from
time to time but we
also respond to your questions here on
the podcast now rob
i don't know this is the lightning round
yeah i don't know i think i've been on
this podcast twice
all i'm going to say is all of my
memories are that your lightning rounds
are longer
than the regular rounds everything we do
is steeped in irony
okay good yeah yeah i remember last time
the lightning round was like
this is not a lightning this is like a
take a walk around the lake
round yeah okay during a lightning storm
really yeah
it's our lightning storm so rob i don't
know if you remember but what we try to
do during the lightning round and we
fail every time
but we um we fail beautifully uh we try
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
but in the real world what we do is
monitor on a bit until we get something
that is
tweetable we've also had a couple days
of prep for this so uh
sean tweezes out our pithy phrases we
call them minimal maxims he puts them in
the show notes so the audience can
copy and share our our pithy answers on
social media
ryan we got a question from simba simba
is rob bell still a christian
[Laughter]
rob thought i think he would say i wrote
a 300 page book about
to answer your question and this literal
question he answers in the book which is
great
yeah um well i mean i'll give you a
pithy answer and then maybe we can
expand on it labels are useful but not
as powerful as everyday actions
um yeah doesn't it mean
would you maybe answer that question
with a question like what do you mean by
christian two characters
of course
that's the pithiest answer ever
that is all i did you could tweet of
course too and like it would just like
people would just like i needed that
today especially like
the entire west coast is on fire and rob
just tweets of course
of course often what presents itself as
religion
is actually a fairly sophisticated egoic
structure
in which the ego grasps and clings to
labels
for a sense of safety a sense of
identity a sense of division
us against them yeah uh a false sense of
security about some coming doom
or judgment so what's really interesting
in the teachings of jesus
he's constantly inviting you to
the love that doesn't need to cling or
grasp
because it's been belonged the entire
time
yeah so litmus test questions um
questions that have a hermeneutic of
suspicion in them
which is um
the the world is sliding off a cliff and
are you
i think you're part of it or are you
it's all built
it's not built around trust it's not
built around a big buoyant
sense that the whole thing is headed in
some fascinating new direction
oh wow it's birthed out of mistrust or
distrust
in a way so like hermeneutic is how you
read something right
so a hermetic of suspicion is uh
and then you think about for many people
for roughly 1400 years in western
culture you've had this idea of original
sin
which is that which is deepest within a
human is wrong
off broken sinful so
no wonder people end up not able to
trust their own
inner knowing they've been taught that
if you look far enough inside of
yourself all you'll see is
evil and darkness but what's fascinating
is the actual tradition begins genesis 1
all human beings bear the divine image
that which is deepest within you
is good yeah of course you we have
tremendous capacities to make a mess of
things
nobody's fuzzy on this but you can see
often this hermeneutic of suspicion that
reads
are you still what are you what are you
i i need
you to give me certain words so that i
can feel
is um rooted in a way of viewing what it
means to be human
that uh you need labels and things to
redeem you as opposed to
you you belonged the whole time
yeah are you on my team or are you the
enemy yeah
the underlying question quite often it's
always funny when religious people
especially people in the jesus tradition
their dominant energies are
moving away from the very things jesus
invites us to be liberated from
he comes to liberate us from questions
that take us in the direction we don't
actually want to be going that aren't
freedom
joy peace non-violence
[Laughter]
i love the uh you talked about the story
in your book of the
farmer who like hired the workers and
they showed up at different times during
the day
but they all get paid the same the same
and
uh that doesn't make any sense you
cannot divide the infinite and there's
no pun he doesn't
and jesus doesn't say and here's the
punch line right he just goes on
right and uh there's also a story that
you don't talk about in your book it
reminded me of the guy who like dropped
everything when he found the pearl
yeah and i'm like and every time i read
that story i'm like this makes no sense
to me
like it has many different meanings i
guess i've heard it explained different
ways
but ultimately um what that
helped me do that part in your book is
start to be comfortable with
not understanding things and you start
off with the quantum physics how you
know there's basically chaos going on
like unexplained chaos and then you
you know there's a macro view of it of
like well we have unexplained chaos that
goes on in the world
and uh and i think religion helps people
find
an answer to all that chaos sure and
helps them organize it yeah yeah holds
it together but the secret is and you
you talk about this
with you know the buddha and jesus and
all the priests and the monks
they got this smile on their face
because they get it
they're like yeah there's a lot of stuff
going on yeah blessed is the one who's
in on the joke
yeah everybody shows up at different
times and gets paid the same amount
yeah yeah yeah all right before we get
into our listener tips
and our added value segment today it
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week
yes indeed questions like does rob bell
believe in an afterlife
also um when is the best time to move on
from
a good situation plus we've got
questions about
the death of god we've got questions
about whether
prayer is useful also questions about
the problems with
fundamentalism and a million more
questions for rob bell
and the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that subscribe to our maximal
episodes on
the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalists to earn an income
because we don't believe in ads by the
way if you're not
a private podcast subscriber you are
literally
missing two-thirds of our show we do
this minimal episode but then
every week we have that maximal episode
ryan
what is a good reason if someone who has
never listened to and we'd want to say
you know what try this out for
three weeks see if it's right for you
it's just two bucks
but what's the what's a compelling
reason to at least try it out
because there's only like 500 spots left
[Laughter]
no man i mean this is where we get to
talk about things that we normally
wouldn't talk about
so for example with today with rob we
get to talk about the afterlife
we get to talk about the death of god we
although that might have came up a
little bit in the minimal episode but
there
are ideas and things that we haven't
quite
fleshed out that we get to flesh out on
these private episodes
with a smaller audience and i think rob
actually is a really good example of
that today
yes indeed so if you want to check that
out theminimalists.com
support just try it out for a few weeks
we think it'll add immense value to your
life
if it doesn't of course just walk away
from it you can still listen to these
minimal episodes whenever you'd like
but the minimalists.com support when you
subscribe you'll get a personal link so
that our private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app ryan what
else you got for us here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners
check them out hi my name is jeanette
and i'm from los angeles and this
message is for
the person that was on beco the becoming
episode asking about what to do with
religious items that she wants to get
rid of but she doesn't want to just
throw in the trash
the there are a lot of hospitals
catholic hospitals
that have gift shops and they would
probably be happy to have a donation of
a cross like hers that she could donate
and somebody else would be happy to have
hi josh and ryan this is heather from
san diego and i have a tip for beth
bev asked for advice about dealing with
beauty products as a minimalist
i've been able to pare down my product
collection quite a lot since i started
my
minimalism journey about a year ago one
thing that has helped me so much
is joining the project pan community
this is a community on the internet
you can just search for project pan on
youtube and instagram
that makes games and challenges out of
using up your makeup
everyone is very supportive people get
really excited when they hit pan on
products and eventually use them up
doing project pants has taught me how
long it takes to use up products
and help me to buy a lot less being
aware of expiration dates of makeup
also helps to pare down your collection
knowing that a foundation only has a
year-long shelf life and takes about six
months or more to use up
will prevent you from buying or owning
more than two at a time
i know ryan mentioned the 2020 rule
which
doesn't always work especially if you
don't own
only drugstore makeup products most
makeup
does cost more than twenty dollars
however the 90-90 rule works
pretty well for some makeup products
when considering their expiration date
remember that open tubes of mascara
should be thrown out after three months
every time you use it more bacteria gets
into the product which is
pretty dangerous considering how close
the wand gets to your eye
also think about how you like to use
makeup do you like to keep it simple or
do you like to have choices
if you like that choices there are so
many versatile products on the market
that
many people already have in their
collections consider rotating through
your eyeshadow palettes to doing a one
month one palette challenge to give your
older palettes some love
you can do this with lip products too
challenge yourself to wear a different
shade every day for a week
finally beth you mentioned wanting to
purchase more ethically i recommend
looking
into the cruelty-free movement
cruelty-free kitty and logical harmony
are great resources
online best of luck on your journey all
right y'all thanks again to
rob bell for joining us today check out
his
new book it is the book that really
we've been waiting for him to write it's
called everything
is spiritual i'll hold it up if you're
watching on
youtube uh you can check it out
audiobook
ebook print book it comes out today the
day this podcast comes out
september 15th 2020.
everything is spiritual by rob bell for
added value this week it's something
else by rob bell since
he's been here and uh something that i
got immense value from
sean and i podcast sean and i went uh
bex was out of town
and rob was giving this talk when was
that 2018
sean 2019 early 2019 maybe it was in the
old world
yeah it was and so it was early 2019
and so sean was my date for this robel
event
uh he was practicing this talk called an
introduction to joy
which is a phenomenal title by the way
and he practiced his talk it was great
the live event was one it was like a
stand-up comedy show but it was also
like a uh inspirational ted talk
and it was everything and none of that
it's hard to even label what it was
although i can tell you that time just
sort of faded away when we were
going through it and i came out of it
and i i really
had some key takeaways i don't want to
ruin it for you so i encourage you to
check it out it's free it's on youtube
it's called an introduction to joy
because he took that talk all around the
country and then he came back to la
and filmed it uh it was andrew morgan
actually directed it he was on our
podcast with rob last time
with the documentary he did and so it is
filmed in
this theater but it is hilarious you'll
want to share it with your friends and
family as soon as i showed it to bex
she was sending it off to her parents
you've got to see this and they were
sending it off to other people
this thing is really going to take off
check it out it's called an introduction
to joy it's on youtube we'll put a link
to that in the show notes
and real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of
the minimalist ryan and i have a little
side project we talk about from time to
time
it's called minimalism life the website
is minimalism.life you can follow
minimalism life on
instagram minimalism life or on twitter
at minimalism on
twitter and what we what we've done is
we partnered with our friend carl from
minimalissimo
and our friend alberto from five style
and then
us the minimalists and also a team of
writers where
we what we try to share is the best of
minimalist
travel the best of minimalist design so
travels five style design is
carl and how dare his website be more
better than ours
more better more better i like this
how to write more better.com
no and so minimalism.life is this place
where we curate the minimalist
well-being minimalist travel minimalist
uh design minimalist aesthetics the
instagram account is beautiful
but we also try to do is it's not just
minimalism we're trying to add value to
your life so we have a team of writers
who right there
as well you can subscribe to the
newsletter also minimalism life has
published its
first book i've got an essay in there
and a bunch of other writers have an
essay in there so you can check it out
it's
just called inside minimalism you're
welcome to check that out we'll put a
link to that in the show notes or you
can just go to
minimalism.life you can check it out
what i like about this
side project is ryan i think you and i
have figured this out over the years
whenever we work on things with people
together there's
it's more difficult you don't get there
as quickly
so to speak but you
accomplish something greater where if
you and i just started minimalism life
on our own hey let's start a little side
project
you know it wouldn't be nearly as good
as what it is now no because we do the
minimalist well-being thing but if you
and i
were trying to do minimalist design and
uh highlighting architecture like we
could learn about that
yeah but we have experts in that area
that we've partnered up with
and so what we have is this beautiful
side project
and within there you can check out
inside minimalism
you can check out the free wallpapers
over there as well
some minimalist wallpapers for your
phone and desktop minimalism.life
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you by the way
rob is doing a virtual tour
for his book everything is spiritual
find that
at rob bell.com it's really fascinating
model what he's doing is
he's going to like a dozen cities
cincinnati and brooklyn
and and la and uh
a bunch of other places see uh seattle
but he's not going there he's gonna be
in his front yard
doing these events with people who he
he's gonna have
certain people he really admires read
the book and he's going to do the event
with them to sort of talk about what
they got from the book
and and so this is going to happen in a
bunch of different cities but the good
news is you don't have to be in seattle
to go to that seattle stop
where you don't be in brooklyn to go to
the brooklyn stop you can be at home so
it's coming to a computer screen
near you it actually starts the day this
episode
comes out robbell.com for details on
that
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com
the minimalist if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails and if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com and if
you leave here today
with one message we hope it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all
see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it